hey guys it is the 13th of October today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
choosing two games for news first up
Treyarch has explained the new realistic
difficulty mode in call of duty black
ops 3 after it was uncovered in the game
for Cheeseman tlie producer Jason
blundell told Xbox achievements in
realistic you have one point of life so
if you shot once you're dead it
completely changes the way you played
the game he added you all have to
survive as a group you end up respecting
the level in a completely different way
and once gunfire opens up everyone just
drops to the ground because of any one
bullet hits you or a grenade goes off
near you and you're dead this is the
first call of duty to feature the
difficulty level past games only
featured recruit hardened and veteran
difficulties this week's destiny update
out of those microtransactions we were
talking about into the game here's what
they do and how much they'll cost you
heading to the other verse trading
company store in game will allow you to
purchase a variety of emotes including
two legendary mode one of them is the
Carlton dance made famous by the
character of Carlton in the fresh prince
because of course it is these cost 500
silver each all other emotes cost 200
silver you can spend 5 real-world
dollars for 500 silver 10 4 1100 or 20
bucks for 2300 if picking up every amote
is the thing you want to do it'll cost
you the equivalent of 38 real world of
dollars all destiny players will get 400
silver to start with which is enough to
buy two standard emotes as they sell for
200 silver each and finely dice has
reported that the Star Wars Battlefront
beta is the largest in the history of EA
senior producers de Gallina end of us da
tia whose name i certainly just
butchered added like Han Solo at the end
of a new hope we're glad you showed up
even more importantly than just showing
up you've been spending a lot of time
playing
great times and leaving us some
invaluable feedback as we continue to
tune and balance the game until launch
star wars battlefront will be out on
November 17 then we are down in that
comment section what you think of Call
of Duty's new realistic difficulty mode
you can add the game spot we've got
stories on blood ones game of the year
edition and a Friday the 13th game
that's everything I help you today as
always let me know what mattered to you
and I will catch you the same time
tomorrow